AOS report that Netanyahu briefed Joe
Biden on the phone that they were going
to shortly launch a ground Invasion and
the story seems quite well sourced when
do you think that might take place if it
is indeed going to take place I do think
it will take place not because netan
wants it to take place not because the
Army wants it to take place but I I
think it's inevitable at this point I
remember during the 50-day war in the
summer of 2014 there was a push from the
Israeli right to do a ground invasion of
Gaza netan ignored that because the army
was worried that it was going to be a
bloody Urban Quagmire you look at what's
happened now though the trigger for this
war is so much bigger than the trigger
for the 2014 War the public mood is very
much in favor of a strong response and
the governing Coalition in Israel is a a
farri coalition so I think there's going
to be unsurmountable pressure to go
ahead with a ground Invasion I think the
military right now needs a few more days
to call up reservists but I think it's
something that within the next week or
so more likely than not will go ahead